Wonderful.
Kiran Chin, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm well, Michael.
Thank you for having me.
Appreciate it.
I am very excited to have you.
I came in here thinking
we're gonna talk primarily
about consulting and MKA insights
and MBA and finance,
but we're gonna start off
with education
because the first thing
that you told me is that
this is something
you're particularly passionate about
and intertwined with your passion now
for helping bridge gaps in education.
I'd love to tie this also
to your personal journey
and to understand a little bit about
where you come from
and sort of the non-linear career pathway
that you took to becoming the CEO
of the very successful MKA Insights.
So Kiran, who are you?
Well I don't know if 20 minutes
will suffice for a life history here, but I'll-
It never does, but we'll try.
So, education is absolutely something
I'm extremely passionate about.
It's one of my core tenets.
It has molded me.
It has driven me,
continues to drive me today.
I'm a constant learner.
I want to absorb as much knowledge
as I can.
I ask a ton of questions,
and that's been me
for as long as I can recall.
And it really started
a very long time ago.
When I came to this country,
I was about five years old.
My parents immigrated here from Pakistan.
They had six children at the time.
- Wow
They had a seventh child
that was born in the states.
So, I'm one of seven.
Where in Pakistan, by the way?
So, we moved around a little bit,
but Hyderabad and Karachi
are kind of the two towns
that my parents hail from.
Wow.
And my parents
always brought us here and said,
"There are no opportunities
or few opportunities in Pakistan,
but in America, with an education,
you can be anything
and do anything you want to be."
The American dream.
American dream. True.
And I'm five years old.
I'm listening to my parents
not fully realizing what that means
until, I realized very early on
and I have high logic centers.
I think how does this work.
Those are the questions that drive me.
And so I would ask,
"Well, why does the grass grow?
How does the sun revolve
around the earth?"
And the responses I got
were very religious
because my parents are very conservative.
And they would say,
"Well, God does this and God does that."
And I would go,
"Well, I don't know."
like I think there's ... here.
And so I, at a very early age,
was six years old.
By six years old,
I knew I was born into the wrong family.
I was very scientific oriented,
wanted to know how the world works,
and the responses I was getting
wasn't feeding
that intellectual curiosity.
And I remember my father said,
"I brought you here for an education.
With an education,
you can do anything, be anything."
and I held on to that.
I believed it.
I started accelerating in school.
I had just a natural ability.
I love academics.
I love books.
So, I accelerated,
and I knew that
that was my ticket out of there.
It wasn't just the religious household
that I butted heads with.
I grew up six, seven kids
in a really impoverished part of town
just outside of Philadelphia.
We did not have a lot,
and I knew that education
was my way out of there
for multiple reasons.
And so, I applied myself
and put myself through school
and continued to focus on education,
and that's allowed me to make the jumps
that I have had in my career
and allowing me to be where I am today.
So, education is a core tenet of mine.
I truly believe that with education
you can do and be anything you want to be,
but you have to believe in it.
Wonderful. I have a few quick questions.
So, out of the seven children,
where are you,
and you're definitely not the youngest,
but where are you in the line?
I am the exact middle child.
I'm the fourth child in the social order.
Wonderful.
And your favorite subjects in school?
Well of course science and math.
So, I'm a STEM child growing up.
There's order, it's tangible,
it's ...
It's predictable.
It's predictable. You know it, right.
There's always an answer to it.
I always struggled with history
and writing,
but reading was also a favorite of mine,
so I was an absolute bookworm growing up.
Wonderful. Okay.
So, you go through college.
Your bachelor's, your master's,
and then MBA.
And then, what's your thinking process?
So, where do you go from there?
Because you both studied finance
as a masters, but you've done
also your business degree.
So, what's next for you?
So, I think this goes back
to why I think education
and exposure to young children
is one of my biggest passions in life,
because when I was an immigrant child,
I did not know what the opportunities
were in front of me.
So I was either going to be
a doctor or a lawyer,
and those were the options.
And when I was asked,
"Well, what are you going to do?"
The follow up question is,
"Well, what do you like doing?"
and I like helping people.
But that isn't an exact career.
But I'm also great at science and math.
And so, the two of what you like to do,
combined with what are you good at,
was never something that at a young age
I understood very well. So I said,
"Well, I want to help people,
but what are those careers?"
And so I'm finding now my journey,
as I reflect back,
that remains true to who I am.
I want to remain helping people,
but I'm also really good
at science, math, and solving problems.
So where I am today,
I solve people's problems for a living.
And it took me
about 20 years after business,
after undergraduate,
to come to that realization.
I like the uncertainty.
I like the chaos.
I like being the first one
in a problem or a challenge
trying to figure it out.
Okay. So, same place that we left off.
We left off talking about STEM.
We just finished
your finance and business degree.
And I was asking,
where are you headed at that point?
Okay. So, wrapping up
my finance and business degree,
I ended up getting a job
out of business school
with a life sciences tools company.
And ended up doing M&A work for them.
And it wasn't what I thought
I was going to do,
because I graduated in 2009,
which was just at the height
of the housing bubble bursting.
And so there was a flood
of financial professionals ...
And prior to going to business school,
I had a very different career
than post business school.
So, I worked in politics
for about three and a half years.
I earned a degree in economics.
And it's not the degree
that I thought I was going to get
being a STEM child.
I thought I was going to go
into some kind of medical field,
and unfortunately, that did not work out.
The bookworm that was removed
from her very conservative household
where we weren't allowed to do very much,
transplanted over to Southern California
with the beaches
and just the beautiful weather.
And for the very first time in my life,
I experienced life
for the very first time.
So, I don't know if I would take
any of the life experiences back.
I would certainly go back
and tell my younger self
to pay more attention
to the organic chemistry
and the biology books
and maybe try and finish out
that scientific degree,
but that was not in the cards for me.
And I think my life where it is today
is just right where it should be,
so I think I'm okay.
But I thought I was going to be a doctor.
That academically was not
in the cards for me.
I switched focus
to be an economics degree.
I didn't quite know what to do with that.
I was fortunate that at Career Day at USC,
which is my alma mater,
I came across a lobbyist.
I found myself interviewing for jobs
at LA County Mayor's office,
at the LA County
Board of Supervisors offices,
and the do gooder in me
wanted to be a part of something.
If it was not in medicine,
then maybe it was in politics.
And so, I started working
for a very highly regarded
Latina politician in LA County.
And it was really tough going
because she had high expectations
and very few people
were ever meeting those expectations.
But it was such a great
learning environment.
I have to tell you,
there were a lot of cuts and bruises
having worked in that office,
but I learned a tremendous amount.
But at the end of the day, I realized
it was disconnected
from my STEM background.
I had a passion for the sciences.
It was just, it didn't feel
like what I should be doing.
And so I wanted to go back
to business school.
Find a way-
But you spent
a pretty long time there, right?
It wasn't just a month or two.
Right. Right.
I was there for about
three and a half years.
Great experiences.
At the tender age of 21, 22 years old
I was managing a $750,000,000
LAC/USC hospital construction project.
Co-managing that
with the Urban Planning Deputy.
I was put in leadership roles
for urban planning projects,
economic redevelopment.
So, I was in a way helping the community
and the constituency.
It just wasn't what I thought
it was going to be,
but I did see the impact
of the work we were doing.
But again,
disconnected from the sciences.
So, it was important for me to go back
and feel reconnected to science and math.
And so, thinking back to business school,
Hey, I want to go to business school.
Use that to leverage
into a career in science and math.
And again, don't know
what that looks like.
I just know I'm gonna get
to the next rung and figure it out
when I get there.
And when I did-
So right before we continue to that part.
You're at the intersection,
you're at a sort of a junction in life
and you're saying,
Yes, I had a wonderful time here
working on these incredible projects,
but I feel that my heart
is someplace else.
My true passion and my progression
throughout my career
is gonna be someplace else.
I'm curious about this decision
to go to business school.
I mean obviously business school
it's a wonderful experience,
but being at university myself,
it is a dilemma that a lot of people have, right.
Business school,
it's not just the financial burden of it,
but it's also the time
that you spend on it.
And a lot of people are wondering
what's the right path.
And for you, that was your path
as you were transitioning careers.
Walk me through a little bit
about the thought process back then
of why you enroll in business school
three and a half years
after you're in the market.
Well, for me, it was a journey
because I was not very happy
in the political role.
Because again,
very disconnected from my core.
And so, I was trying to find
alternative roles
and it just was not working out for me
because every conversation
or informational discussion I had,
always came back to the fact
that they did not understand
how a job in politics and government
translated into a job
in the private sector
or in banking or anything of the sort.
And the feedback that I was getting
from a lot of the individuals
I spoke to said,
"You know what?
Maybe you should try to go back
to business school and get a degree
where you're academically trained
in the principles of
how a business is run,
how businesses operate.
And that will allow you to at least
get a foot in the door."
And at that point, I said,
You know what?
I'd like to try that.
I'm hungry. I'm a hard worker.
I'm going to do anything that I can do
in order to get my foot in the door,
because once I get there,
I know I'll be fine.
And so, that confidence
carried me through the guidance
and advice of many people
who carried me through.
And that's how I find myself
going to business school.
So, now you're running a company,
MKA Insights.
Tell me a little bit about
what you're trying to do there
and how you're now
bridging that gap with STEM
and your other passions to also helping.
Well so, excuse me.
MKA Insights
is a management consulting firm
which for those who don't know,
and I didn't know, I think I arrived
at this point in my life late,
it's a consulting firm that works
with managers, business leaders,
executives, business owners.
And the way that I describe it is
we like to work with people
at the top of the pyramid
helping them solve
their toughest business challenges.
So, do you want to go to market in Europe?
Do you want to launch
a disruptive new technology?
Do you want to expand in Asia Pacific?
Those are the kinds of business challenges
that people at the top of the company
are often faced with,
and those are the kinds of things
that we enjoy doing.
Now, we also have a very specific focus
or industry focus
coming from the sciences.
We love technology.
We love science.
And we like to stay with the high science,
high technology vertical.
So, we work with
clinical diagnostic companies,
medical device companies,
life sciences tools,
biologics manufacturing tools,
cell and gene therapy.
So, those are kind of the verticals that we serve.
And again, whatever business challenge
that they have, we love taking on.
So, that's what we're working on
as a company.
And it stays focused with STEM.
And the great thing about it is
we get to experience the innovation
that this industry has to offer,
and it really fuels us and keeps us going.
We are part of
some fantastic conversations,
whether it's covid-19 related,
whether it's STEM
and cell and gene therapy related.
And as of late, we've started getting
conversations and dialogues with company
in the aerospace sector.
And so, we're really, really excited
about the kinds of innovation,
the boundary pushing technology
and thought that is occurring
in the high science,
high technology sectors that we serve.
So, we're really excited about it.
Now, are these long term engagements,
short term engagements?
Just paint me a picture a little bit
of what is tangible part work
that you can do?
So, I'm coming in.
Let's say I'm a biologist
and I have a company
that I'm offering some product.
And I also want to now offer it to Europe,
not just the United States.
So, I assume that I would be able
to come to you and say,
"Listen, I'm wondering about
what is the best way to do this."
or "I'm having trouble
penetrating the market.
Maybe you can help me price
or you can help me think
through my product better."
Are those the types of things
people come with?
Exactly.
So, that is an exact case study
that we did
or exact engagement that we did.
So, we work with companies
that want to expand into Europe.
And so, we'll do an evaluation
of their current footprint.
We'll do our own market research,
discovery, look at their capabilities.
I mean, we ask a ton of questions
and that goes back to
one of the core tenets
which is education.
I mean we can't, in good conscious,
put together a plan that says
"You should do this"
without knowing as much as we can
about the current industry dynamics,
the regional dynamics, the company,
its strengths and capabilities,
its limitations, management challenges,
and the like.
And once we get that
holistic picture developed,
then we have an iterative discussion
with those business leaders and say,
"Hey, we think this is the direction
that's right for you guys.
Is that in line with what you would like
to see happen?"
And it isn't a plan
that we concoct in isolation and say,
"Go, do this."
and it's completely unrealistic.
We do it in partnership with our clients
who need to own the management decisions
once we leave,
because the whole goal
of working with our clients
is to enable them and empower them
to do this long after we leave.
Because paying a consultant
to be a part of your management team
can become extremely expensive.
And so, we don't want to do that
to our clients.
We want to have an impact,
we want to have a measurable impact,
and we want to teach them a few things
along the way that they should retain
as part of their own
business growth journey.
Wow. Okay. That's just incredible.
Quick question before we have to wrap up
and I'll ask the most important question,
but how do you retain knowledge
within an organization like this?
So, you said before a case study
and then you changed it
to an engagement,
but really, these are case studies
that at the end you go to business school
and you study these things as case studies
about how do you take a certain problem
and you tackle it through
different directions
and you see what the optimal outcome is.
But how do you maintain that knowledge
within an organization,
because these things must be coming up
that are reminding you
of previous things that happened.
And maybe one partner
dealt with one problem
and another partner is dealing
with a similar problem.
How does that knowledge retain
throughout an organization?
Well, we write everything down.
So, we like to document
what we've done in the past
because one of the very first questions
that we ask is,
"Who's done this before?"
So, this is one of the
business school 101 questions
that you learn on day one
when you're doing case study evaluation.
You look around the room,
you look at your team, and you go
"Who's done this before?
Who knows something about this?"
So, in order for us
to be able to ask that question,
we document
what our work efforts have been,
and then we'll reflect back
on prior engagements
and use those as a case study
to document our new clients efforts.
That's wonderful. Okay.
So, 20 minutes go by very, very quickly,
but I have to ask you
the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And you warned me.
I know you warned me.
But not enough ahead in advance.
So, this is not a huge commitment,
but I'd still love to know
how you think about yourself
or how you would like others
to think about you.
So, the first one comes to mind
fairly easily.
I'm a problem solver.
I like problems.
I mean it can be mine, someone else's,
doesn't matter.
My brain is constantly on.
So, I love a good problem.
And then the other words
to describe me are
I don't know how this is an exact word,
but I appreciate brevity.
So, make your point.
Get it across.
Use as few words as possible.
We've all got lots of things to do.
So, be mindful of your time.
And I don't know
if there's a third word to describe me.
I am what I am.
I guess I'm very honest.
I'm very transparent.
There's not a lot of things that I hide,
and I pride myself on that
because I really stink at lying,
and I learned that lesson
a really long time ago.
So I'm forced to be honest,
and I appreciate that in others as well.
Kiran, thank you very much for the honesty
and for sharing your journey.
This was wonderful,
and I can't wait
to share this to the world.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much. I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
Take care.